hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the second day of the finals it's
magnus cross and with the white pieces
against vladislav artemyev magnus won
the first match and then he started the
second match by winning the first game
second game where artemia had the white
pieces ended in a draw and now magnus
again with the white pieces in the third
game it's again a very impressive game
so let's dive straight into it uh magnus
with the white pieces opens with e4 now
we have c5 by artemia he goes for the
sicilian defense knight to f3 uh we have
d6 and d4 so just normal as sicilian
captures captures knight f6 knight to c3
and a6 now going for the knight of
sicilian and now bishop to e to the
opochinski variation
we have g6 artemis uh preparing to
fianchetto his dark square bishop and
the magnus uh uh well sort of
immediately starts the attack with the
g4
uh we have h6 preventing g5 and now
bishop to e3 later on you can play a
move like f3 and then continue with h4
g5 and well all depending on what black
plays uh bishop to g7 and now f3
strengthening his position so we
basically transposed into the uh
classical dragon
we have b5 uh uh advancing this pawn on
the queen side preparing standard moves
like bishop b7 97 rook to c8
and now uh there are a few games where
queen to d2 was played but here we have
the immediate a3 and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how artemiev continues
we have bishop to b7 uh queen to d2
magnus prepares the castle queen side
and now knights to c6 attacking the
knight in the center we have queen side
castles and now artemia wants to start
the attack as soon as possible
and plays b4 now uh wha what does mag
what can magnus do here well he starts
by capturing the knight on c6 uh and now
if you go for this b captures on c3 yes
it does come with an attack on the queen
uh we're simply going to capture and now
we defend our knight and if something
like rook to c8 then it's not a problem
uh we can simply move it or bury it
queen to c7 just putting pressure on the
knight here we're just going to move it
knight to the a5 and now you could trade
here but it's not uh
nothing for for black to look forward to
this bishop here isn't very impressive
the the knight here is actually pretty
good you can play king to d2 bring the
rooks to the b file double up here so
a pretty good position for white
so instead after knight captures on c6
we have bishop captures first and now a
captures on b4 so magnus wins upon here
but it's exactly what artemia wanted
queen to b8 and now he wants to play a5
and perhaps open up the position uh we
have knight to d5 by magnus now uh
defending the b4 pawn uh once again and
now uh you have to play bishop captures
on d5 here uh but uh sorry you have to
play knight characters on d5 but that
tim you've played bishop captures on d5
and this really puts him in a difficult
situation here after knight captures on
the e5 it is a little bit different for
example if pawn captures so we're going
to play bishop to b5 uh and then if
let's say c4 attacking the bishop we can
play bishop to a4 and it's a very very
unclear position where it would be black
who kind of has the attack but these
pawns are
well they are quite impressive so white
should be better here but maybe you know
for a rapid game could be a little bit
easier for for black to play but okay
after knight to d5 artemia played bishop
captures on d5 but now it's a bit
different we have e captures on d5 and
now a5 trying to open up the a file for
his rook and magnus says thank you for
the past pawn now my pawn here on b5 is
defended i also have the b6 square
covered so i like my position here but
artemia will of course continue pushing
this pawn with a4 and now bishop to d4
at some point this knight will move so
we don't want to worry about this dark
square bishop honing in on that b2 pawn
so here we have castles party
and king to b1 now a3 trying to open up
the a file but magnus says nope that's
not happening we have queen to c8 uh
now uh
helping out with with the e6 square but
also at some point uh you will uh you
will have use for for the queen on the c
file uh we have c4 by magnus and now a2
with check we have king the a1 again
because the bishop is on d4 we're
perfectly safe here there are no dangers
from uh black's dark square bishop we
have rook to e8 now preparing to bust
open through the e file and now rook h
to e1 by magnus we have e5 attacking the
bishop here and the magnus happily
trades on e6 alpha song so captures we
have rook captures on e6 uh and now
bishop to d3 uh we have d5 now the queen
is uh uh nicely placed here uh and the
black has to figure out how to white has
to figure out how to how to counter this
see if you play something like c5 yes it
seems like you're getting uh
uh two two connected past pawns here but
uh we can actually capture this with the
queen that's the problem uh and now if
bishop captures we can just play knight
to e4 check open up a discovery here and
pick up white's queen so you have to be
careful not to overextend those pawns
right away so after d5 magnus just plays
queen to b2 gets his queen to safety and
now you are putting a lot of pressure
here on this knight uh so d captures on
c4 we have bishop captures on c4
attacking the rook we have trade on e1
rook characters rook captures and now
queen to d8 uh defending the knight here
and also putting pressure on this bishop
uh and here you could try a lot of
things but you never want to trade if
you trade here it's just game over
black's going to capture with the queen
and after captures captures it's game
over there's no square for your king you
have to give up the rook and bishop
captures will be checkmate so magnus
starts white uh with a h4 he wants to
play g5 kick the knight away and trade
his bishop here so g5 and here we have
captures h captures h captures and now
again magnus really wants to get the g5
in so he starts by sacrificing the uh f4
pawn uh there really isn't anything
better so g captures on f4 we have g5
and now you can't really move the knight
if you move the knight and try and trade
here captures capture is just g6 and
that's it you can't move the pawn white
just wins easily so here we reach the
position from the thumbnail and of
course artemis captured on d4 with the
queen he played bishop captures on d4 so
sacrificing the queen temporarily magnus
of course has to has to capture it we
have queen captures on d4 and now knight
the g4 and now the queen will be
captured there's nothing you can do
about this if rookie five both the
knight and the bishop cover e5 so also
that doesn't help but there is only one
move that wins the game for magnus so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh finding it as
like i said it's the only move that wins
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures an
f7 that's the good stuff and now the
problem is the king cannot capture this
bishop if you capture it then comes the
rook sacrifice and now after you capture
the rook now the bishop is not
undefended we're going to capture it
with check and now we keep our queen so
of course black will not allow this he
played king to f8 but now comes rook the
e8 with check with the same idea if you
capture then rookie seven and the the
same idea applies so rook captures rook
was played but now magnus just plays
queen captures on g7 so now giving the
bag the queen but on his terms we have
king captures and bishop capture 78 and
what does this mean for magnus well it
means that he's up a pawn and that's how
these guys play chess you sacrifice a
queen to win a pawn
and uh
it's uh completely lost for artemiev yes
this past pawn is very very close to
queening but that is not happening he
pushes f3
but magnus easily finds the move because
it's the only move you have to stop the
pawn and it helps by because by playing
b6 the free up the b5 square for your
bishop you're also pushing your own pass
pawn which is of course completely
winning so here knights the e3 you know
you don't have
you don't gain anything by pushing the
pass pawn because the bishop can easily
stop it uh b7 uh by magnus in knight the
c to check now he wants to
he has to stop the pass beep on somehow
king captures an a2 knight before check
we have king to a3 now knight to a6 so
guarding against the queening we have
bishop to b5 attacking this knight and
now knight to b8 and now the problem is
of course you know when the bishop is uh
when this knight is boxed in like this
the bishop is not letting it out so uh
this knight is now trapped here forever
uh we have bishop to d3 uh magnus says i
don't need to keep control of the knight
i need to keep an eye on this king
because now the pawn
and the bishop are creating a wall so
the white king cannot reach this pawn
and there there's really not much more
artemis can do he plays knight d7 sort
of trying to maybe you know wait to see
what magnus will do but now just king b4
uh we have f2 but now king to b5 we have
king to f7 now comes b4 uh we have king
to e6 now comes king to a6 king to d6
now comes king to a7 so now you're ready
to promote this pawn to a queen
and win the knight so king to c7
guarding this square but now comes g6
and he was in this position on move 49
that vladislav artemy resigned to the
game and with it the match as magnus won
the first game second game ended in a
draw and now magnus gets a win so it's a
two two and a half points already for
magnus uh and there is no way for
artemis to tie the second match to four
to even force tie breaks so uh yeah
basically the only uh winner team we've
got was that um uh third game in the
first match where magnus uh made a mouse
slip but it was a really funny mouse
slip because magnus was uh he he was
hovering over a square with uh with his
queen he wanted to place i think it was
the e7 square uh and then he decided
against it and he wanted to put it back
uh to where it was i think on e5 maybe
uh but um
he he accidentally dropped it on e6 and
he didn't even realize and he thought uh
that it was still his move and only
after a full minute uh when artemis
played the move he realized that he
actually played a move that you know he
didn't uh he didn't want to play so uh
yeah kind of funny uh not only was it a
mouse slip but also magnus did not
realize that he even played the move uh
but yeah here in this position you
resign uh you cannot defend against both
of these threats so uh at some point
you're gonna have to move with knight v8
then we push this pawn and okay you can
play knight c6 check but we're gonna
play king a8 and now again it's
impossible to prevent both pawns if you
play this the guard this one then this
pawn queens and the vice versa
now after g6 magnus wins the second
match and the entire
big match which makes him the winner of
the aimchess us rapid knockouts 2021
and uh that there we have it and i've
seen a lot of people uh writing in the
comments that oh yeah and and niepo is
gonna really uh get it in november that
magnus is completely on fire but uh even
though okay artemiev is an amazing
player i still would not say that he is
as good as nepo
and uh if nepo was in the finals i think
nepo would also have
well have a really really uh
good time playing against well pretty
much anyone so i think uh regarding
classical games it's going to be fun
because it's different in uh if you
remember in 2016 in new york when magnus
played against uh
karjakin
it was um okay he he lost one game and
then he somehow won one game which was
you know uh they we had two decisive
games in the in the classical uh but
then against uh fabi in london it was 12
uh draws uh you know 12 consecutive draw
so that was very very uh tough work but
now i don't think it'll be like that i
think we're gonna have a lot more uh
action and maybe a bit more decisive
games in the classical section uh but
we'll see who knows you know the the
engines have uh
gone a long way uh since the last world
championship match and who knows what
what's in store for us
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and this short coverage
uh by me of this tournament uh i would
like to thank christopher alexander
sopaked5.com lynch and natalie rory
o'connor and david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh
to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and checking out whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day